mr. tea time and Obama plays the
trombone it's episode 23 of IMG is this
Wolverine or to Batman's and this is
where to get all our cursors grandpa's
awesome then still awesome now
especially when they do this here are
women's faces from all over the world
averaged together by software and can
you name each video game character in
this image oh sorry this image to see
shadow 502 teased image close-up and to
get answers follow the links below where
you can find links to every image in
this episode
your sweetheart might like these if he
or she likes epic sculptures made out of
crayons her Williams also makes dogs
underwear headphones and a redhead if
you don't have enough crayons just carve
the ones you do have into animals or use
all that extra snow you've got it here's
a squirrel that likes acorns or tearing
children's heads off
Terry border uses food and objects from
around the house to make a Trojan horse
a mail order plastic girlfriend a
matchbook brooch and a lint roller cat
he also noticed that the Apple logo
upside down looks kind of like yep now
it is time for a montage how about
animals in pockets
these things aren't sculptures at all in
fact that are flat but with great
perspective and shading they have the
illusion of dimension and here's Conan
O'Brien made out of Cheetos
Bill Cosby made out of jell-o shots but
what could make these Disney Princesses
so excited oh okay
if that heats you up too much cool down
your car while making yourself look cool
it's just too bad that r2d2 always puts
hoes before Bros now if you're totally
lost
check out Star Wars Episode four in
Icona scope the entire movie now when
you're done give someone a high five or
close your fist in the last second for a
hand turkey if all else fails grab a pen
and make yourself a hand giraffe but now
let's study some science fair projects
the only thing better than this kids
sweater is this t-shirt and here's a
science lesson things change and that's
not always bad on facebook.com slash
Vsauce gaming you guys have been
submitting cool stuff as always a
toaster that burns skulls into your
toast and woody being epic be sure to
like us on Facebook to see more images
and submit your own click on any of
these pictures to watch other episodes
of IMG
and as always thanks for watching